crer hit rock bottom 3 months ago when
this picture went viral of him throwing
out the first pitch while weighing 275
lbs it was at this moment that Bert said
quote never did I think it would come to
this I'm sharing this photo to hold
myself accountable it's horrible but
that picture that picture is the worst
of it that picture of my body's fat
catching up to my body your stomach does
look crazy right there I mean it doesn't
look real 12 Weeks Later Bert is down a
whopping 45 lb and shared this body
comparison to his Instagram this is
quite the accomplishment for the machine
and none of it would be possible without
the moment